hi my name is alex ramose and i own
acquisition.com and our portfolio
companies will do 85 million this year
and i have absolutely nothing to sell
you what i want to talk about today is
one of the the pivotal moments of my
life that that took me from uh
really just getting into a head-on
collision in a dui and having basically
no money to my name to you know 12
months later having three million
dollars in profits not knowing what to
do with it
there was a series of decisions that
happened
in that period of time that radically
transformed my life and so i want to
talk to you about one of the more
significant ones today
and so uh kind of like i just alluded to
leading into my dui head-on collision i
had six gyms two with one partner
i had
uh
four three with another partner and then
i had one on my own so i had all these
kind of weird arrangements that were
going on in my life at that time
um i also had a partner that i was doing
a 50 50 split for
dental agency work and another and the
same partner we also had an agency
together for chiropractic agency work
i'm also doing in-person gym launches so
that means that i'm i was flying out
in person and doing gym turnarounds and
trying to launch gyms
and at the time i was so stressed that i
was drinking i mean probably half a
bottle every night just to honestly not
to get drunk but just to not be stressed
it took me a really long time to just
even like function you know what i mean
in the morning because i was so spread
thin
mentally and what i want to kind of talk
you through is some of the decisions and
how i thought through them because i
don't know where you're at right now and
it doesn't really matter what the scale
is of what the decisions are because
i've made decisions like this at
multiple times my life i ended up going
to an attention coach i know that sounds
ridiculous but i went to a coach to help
me manage my attention and so one of the
things that i think us as entrepreneurs
we think about all the time is like you
know we're managing our time we're
trying to be productive and i worked
every hour of the day that i was awake
and yet i still didn't have that much
money at the time everything was tied up
and you know the gyms and all that kind
of stuff and cash flow for employees and
all that kind of jazz and
this uh this coach had kept telling me
he's like you need to you know you need
to aggregate your attention you need to
focus he's like you're spread all over
the place i pretty much just like would
nod along and and listen and i tried to
do some of the stuff they told me to do
but um i wasn't making i mean i was
making some progress
but it wasn't until
i drank so much that i ended up
getting into a head-on collision about
60 miles an hour on the highway
and i actually walked away
from that and uh it wasn't i didn't hit
anyone i was actually getting pulled
over and there was a car that was in
this in the side the shoulder
that was turned off it was dark
and so i was looking over my shoulder um
and just kind of going from lane to lane
as i was you know getting into the
shoulder as i was getting pulled over as
i was getting pulled over by the cop in
the shoulder there's a black car and i
just i nailed it and so anyways uh they
say that because i was drunk i was
really relaxed and that's why i didn't
get any injuries who knows but anyways i
stepped out of the car you know i'm i'm
getting whatever they do you know sign
you know sign paperwork whatever and um
the next day uh after layla picked me up
from jail as my girlfriend not um not my
wife at the time she was like this guy's
a real winner
anyways and so she picks me up and the
next day
i have a conversation with him obviously
and he's like
he's like
your lack of making decisions is going
to kill you
and i remember him saying that to me and
he was like the reason you're stressed
is because you have all these decisions
that you know you should make and you're
not making them
i wanted to make this because uh i
wanted to talk about probably the the
the second hardest decision i made in my
life the hardest decision was quitting
my job probably the second hardest
decision was was the decisions that i
had it was a multitude of decisions that
i had to make that i knew i was supposed
to make and i just didn't know how to
confront them and it seems like it's a
common theme in my life that when i only
make decisions when i'm literally
confronted with my own mortality and so
if you notice that as a common theme
among my stuff it's because for some
reason i can't get myself to decide to
do things unless i literally think i'm
going to die and so i saw this and it
became the the catalyst for me making a
number of changes in my life and so what
i did over the next you know really the
next 48 hours was a rapid series of
decisions that consolidated all my
attention um into one thing and so
that's what i want to talk to you about
so the first thing i did i called up the
partner that i had the two agencies with
and i said hey i can't do this i'm doing
gym agency work where i'm flying out and
doing turnarounds i'm doing dental
agency work and we're doing chiropractor
hdr i was like i can't do any of it so
i'm i'm just i'm out i just was like i'm
out you can have everything i'm done
it was like okay
um and that was a horrible conversation
to have because i felt like i was
letting a partner down and then i called
up um
the partner that i had
in uh
in
in in the the multitude of gyms more of
the gyms um and i said hey you know
how can we figure out a way for us to
you know walk away i want to do
this gym launch stuff um and so you know
we ended up working it out and i
basically gave away the gyms
at fire sale numbers more or less i was
able to sell uh
two of them successfully in a for a
better number but the rest of them i
pretty much just gave away and then uh
the partner that i had that i was in the
new gym with i said you know hey i'm i'm
i don't i don't want to do this anymore
i need to focus on on gym launch
obviously all those conversations did
not go you know super well they weren't
super well received but i think i just
was only able to have the courage to do
it because i had almost died the night
before and so it just gave me this
massive perspective where i was like am
i i'm so afraid of letting these people
down that i that i might die and so i
ended up making that all those decisions
just in a matter of like a day or two
and and having those conversations and
so i think the the the lesson for me
um that i've taken with me that's been
the most valuable thing of this is one
you won't die when you make those those
calls but second
a lot of times i feel like when i was a
newer entrepreneur and even as i feel
that as i accumulate unmade decisions
right i think we accumulate these unmade
decisions
unma un unconfronted conversations and
what happens is there's like a portion
of my brain in my decision making my
thinking power that just gets allocated
to this chunk this this decision right
that needs to be made that is unmade
that i know i should make and i probably
know what the right call is but it's
just sitting there unmade and so it's
like as we start accumulating these
things it's like my my actual amount of
of thinking power continues to decrease
until you get to the point where you're
so reactive because you have no brain
power and as a small like corollary to
that i don't know if you've ever like if
you remember when you were a kid and you
had like homework or something like that
and you were like staring at a math
problem you can figure it out and um and
you know you you're staying up late into
the night you're like whatever i'm gonna
go to sleep and see if i can think about
the morning
and then you wake up the next day and
you feel refreshed and and you look at
the problem and it seems obvious you're
like oh it does here it is and then it's
done right
um i feel like that is the that is an
expression of having far more attention
far more decision-making power far more
thinking power um because you can
concentrate on this one thing and all of
a sudden it seems easy and i think that
business and life are a lot like that at
least they have been for me where it's
like if i feel like
like
simple decisions are are take an
inordinate amount of effort it's because
i'm too distracted i have too many
things too many unmade decisions too
many unconfronted conversations that i
need to have
and um those can be life conversations
with a spouse it can be conversation
with parents they can be conversations
with siblings they can be conversations
with business partners they make
conversations with employees they can be
decisions that must be made
and i think one of the power most
powerful things that that i've tried to
remember is like i'm only one decision
away from changing my life just one
decision i'm one decision away from from
changing my life i can quit my job that
is one decision right i can start a
business that is one decision these are
decisions that we have to make at some
point in our life and these are like the
crossroads there's two kind of major
major themes that i have one is that
most people don't regret doing things
they regret not doing things and so i
know that when i die i don't want to
regret not having done things i'd rather
do things than fail so that i do not
have the regret and i'll have the
experience and having that kind of
thought process has been extremely
helpful for me to draw back to the point
of uh this this whole thing when i
made these decisions and layla was with
me because she basically said as well
after i got off the phone call with the
coach she was like
if you don't change things she's like
i'm not like this this has got to change
like i'm not going to be around she kind
of indicated that she didn't say it
directly but i think i understood i
could read between the lines and i
valued my relationship with her uh more
than a lot of the other things that were
going on in my life and i could tell
that she was a little bit outside of the
storm that was alex hermosie at the time
the storm of chaos
and so
she was like you have to make these
calls and so i made these calls
physically like phone calls and also
these decisions
and what resulted next was really the
you know i had to suffer the pain of the
consequence of those decisions which was
very hard for me
um but i felt determined that i had made
those decisions i felt confident and i
felt like i had more attention and more
bandwidth at my disposal because i had
made the tough calls and i started
believing in myself more because i was
like man if i can make these calls then
i can do this next thing and so that was
kind of i would say the explosion that
created the beginning momentum of like i
can do this
after i basically shut down as many
different side projects as i could
that's when i went all in on gym launch
and so gym launch actually was started
in 2016 which was probably
2016 into the first half of 2017 was
like the worst 18 months of my entire
life and that was also when i
coincidentally met layla my wife
so she saw me at the absolute worst
and for some reason decided to stay with
me because she believed which is why
she'll always have my my eternal
gratitude we made this call i ended
three partnerships i sold
sold or let go of fire sold
you know at the time i guess if you if
you were just trying to number those
like eleven nine businesses or something
that was going on and so this is one of
those things where people were like man
i have i have i have so many businesses
uh you know et cetera and it's like
you have to do them in the right
sequence like i didn't even i wasn't
barely making any money and i had all
these businesses so i could feel good
about my status when in reality i knew
that i wasn't that successful and so
um it was only when layla was like this
gym launch thing is working like all we
have to do is just give it our full
attention and it will work at that point
i felt so i want to stay defeated but i
also felt like my my slate was clean
right i had cleaned the slate and like i
pushed everything off the side
in the face of my of my mortality
that the stress of not making these
decisions was going to kill me and so um
that's when i just focused full in on on
on gym launch and um and things kind of
took off and i think in another video
i'll tell you that story of how how
things actually started there um because
i think it's valuable for a lot of
people who are going through it right
now um but i guess i wanted to make this
video because the the takeaway that i
had from that is that i'm always one
decision away from changing my life and
um i'm often one conversation away
from getting my attention back i'm one
decision away from getting all my
attention back
from where i'm feeling distracted so i
don't know where you're at right now but
the most valuable thing that we have as
entrepreneurs is not our time but our
attention if we have all of the time but
we have a million things going on we are
useless because we have no decision
making power we have no thinking power
because little pieces of our brain are
being allocated these unformed
unfinalized decisions um that maybe can
cost your life and i don't know i mean
it did almost for me which is why i've
been so ruthless with my attention since
then um and so and had to by
by consequence so disciplined with my
focus it's not because i'm naturally
that way so hopefully this story will
illustrate that to you that this was not
something that naturally came to me but
was a decision that i had to make to
save myself and so um don't know where
you're at right now my name's alex from
rosie we own acquisition.com uh our
portfolio companies now do about 85
million a year i have nothing to sell
you um i made this channel because a lot
of people are broke and i don't want you
to be one of them and i think that
everyone has 100 within their control to
become the top one percent of the united
states which is already the top whatever
percent in the world so anyways lots of
everyone um if you did like this hit the
subscribe button if you didn't love you
either way uh and i'll see you next
video bye